في الاثناء قالت القناه الثال عش
الاسرائيليه ان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو عرقل في الايام الاخيره مقترحا
لصفقه تبادل اسر صاغه وزراء مجلس الحرب
لكن ديوان رئاسه الوزراء رد على اتهام
نتنياهو بعرق مقترح تبادل الاسرى بالقول
ان رئيس الحكومه رفض فقط طلب حماس انهاء
الحرب من جهتها قالت القناه الثانيه ع
الاسرائيليه ان حزب العمل سيقدم مقترحا
لسحب الثقه من الحكومه بسبب عجزها عن
استعاده رهائن اما القناه السابعه
الاسرائيليه فنقلت عن وزير الامن القومي
ايتمار بن جفير قوله ان نتنياهو يرتكب
اخطاء واذا توقفت الحرب فلن تكون هناك
حكومه وقال وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
تمار بنفير ايضا ان على اسرائيل احتلال
غزه والبقاء في مراكز المدن داخلها
وان يتم الدفع بخطه لتهجير سكانها بنفير
اضاف في مقابله مع القناه الثالثه عش
الاسرائيليه ان على نتنياهو ان يختار بين
طريق بنفير او طريق بيني جانس في اشاره
للفروق بينهما وتحديدا فيما يتعلق بمرحله
ما بعد
الحرب ما الذي تقترحه اذا اقترح او ان لا
نخرج من مراكز المدن في غزه
وان نبقى هناك نعم نعم احتلال غزه والبقاء
فيها وهل نصبح مسؤولين عن حياه سكانها لا
ما يجب فعله هو الدفع بخطه هجره تشجيع
طوعي طبعا يتيح ذهبهم انت تقول يجب ان
يبقى الجيش في غزه وبارادته نقوم بطردهم
هل هذا عملي طبعا طبعا اذا قمنا باخضاع
فهذا
ممكن